what's up guys bang bang i want to
quickly talk about the brain drain yes
everyone is leaving legacy tech and
finance wall street everyone's leaving
silicon valley everyone's leaving and
where are they going they are going to
the bitcoin and crypto industry we're
now seeing articles lots and lots of
entrepreneurs founders venture
capitalists in silicon valley they're
struggling to keep their talent their
most talented engineers their most
talented employees all leaving for the
frontier trying to go figure out how the
hell they can make more money and have a
bigger impact on the world in the
bitcoin crypto industry on top of that
we're now starting to see articles also
about wall street the people who already
left they're going to greener pastures
but the people who stayed behind they
are pissed they realize that all the
folks in the crypto industry are making
more money than they are it's absolutely
hysterical to see people on wall street
now being upset because the young kids
the kids who saw the frontier who
weren't scared that were courageous
enough had the conviction they left and
they went and started to build the
future of this new digital financial
system so expect more of this i don't
know if we get to the point where
there's capitulation from all of the
companies but i do think that this is a
topic going into 2022 one of the big
trends we're gonna continue to watch is
this brain drain as more employees leave
silicon valley and wall street and start
to head into the crypto industry one
you're going to get a complete increase
in quality of the employees of the
founders of the investors focused on
building this new role but also too is
those legacy companies both large
corporations and legacy startups in
those legacy industries they're all
going to be struggling trying to figure
out how the hell do they compete now if
i'm one of those new crypto companies
one of those new bitcoin companies and i
want to recruit these folks i'm going to
what i'm saying hey stop helping build
the old world we don't need more
centralized entities we don't need more
of the same instead leave your dumb job
and come help us build a cool new system
that's what the opportunity here is is
you don't have to work to just simply
reinforce the same trends we've had for
decades and decades and decades you now
can have real world impact on billions
of people and it's early so you can go
ahead and actually have a material say
in how this new world ends up being
built now if i'm one of the old
incumbents you know what i'm saying hey
it's super risky i don't know if you
should go do that let me pay you a
little bit more let me go ahead and make
it a little bit less risky for you to
stay here so ultimately i think the
employees are going to end up being the
real winners here they're either going
to stay and get paid that's right baby
big time money for the people who end up
staying but the people who leave that's
just like the explorers back in the day
there's risk but if you end up being a
part of the solution there is enormous
benefit to you both from an intellectual
curiosity standpoint from an impact on
the world and of course if you create
change in the world if you create
products that people want then you get
paid and that's what the name of the
game is right now is we're watching
those top employees the highest quality
people the brain drain is real they are
leaving in droves from silicon valley
and wall street and they're moving into
the bitcoin crypto industry one of the
big trends of 2022 it's only starting
and mark my words when we're talking
about this a year from now we're going
to be saying damn that had a significant
impact on wall street silicon valley and
the real winner is going to be bitcoin
and crypto companies so we'll see out
there if you're thinking about leaving
jump baby scared money don't make money
i'll see you guys on the internet